SCP-682, the indestructible reptile, versus
SCP-241, “Good Home Cooking”.
What happens when you
introduce the humanity-hating
lizard to a cookbook that sends the person
eating the recipes into anaphylactic shock?
Let’s find out.
A portion of 682’s skin tissue was fixed
to a steel rod, which was held by a D-Class
and used to turn the pages of 241.
The cookbook displayed 99 new recipes, including
three in an unknown language, two that were
completely incomprehensible, and one that
contained a memetic kill agent.
The remaining recipes all contained instructions
that made accurate preparation impossible,
such as “marinate for 900 trillion years”.
D-Class personnel was tasked with preparing
these 93 recipes.
Upon completion, each dish was served directly
to the lizard.
Naturally, it was able to consume all 93 meals
without any difficulty.
For 682, this was most likely one of the more
enjoyable termination attempts.
Bon appétit!